[Musique]
pendant très
longtemps le mauvais sexe et leur passeport
vous savez comme celui-ci un
tel spectacle d'une personne
euh
quand
je prétendais être une femme et j'ai essayé
très fort
il y avait toujours quelque chose qui me dérangeait
et
donc
au moins je  demander au gouvernement de
dire qui je suis en tant que personne
et vous savez que je peux me retourner et dire
ouais bien dans ma carte d'identité le gouvernement
me voit comme qui je suis et peut-être que vous devez
commencer à
me voir comme qui je suis
et je suis désolé  je ne voulais pas pleurer euh
oui c'était la première fois que je me voyais
dans un formulaire d'identification
et quand tu sais que le
gouvernement fait plus de reconnaissances euh avec des
gens au-delà du binaire
euh
je ne sais pas ça me fait me sentir plus en sécurité
vous